don't you ever let anybody take you okay
no I'm gonna stay with me this is my
kitty okay you can go bye-bye oh sorry
am i inconveniencing you I'm
inconveniencing her kion who starts the
comedy duo key and Peele I'm just going
to refer to them as that throughout the
majority this review because saying
their full names will just take so long
and it'll get superfluous and you guys
know who they are key and Peele
they had their very own sketch comedy
show on Comedy Central and I've always
thought they were really funny they were
the best parts of other films that
weren't that good of recent years like
pitch perfect - he was by far my
favorite part of that movie so in this
film the cat Keanu gets catnapped by
some gang members and because of their
deep intense love for this cat they
infiltrate this gang by pretending to be
gang members themselves they got to act
super hardcore to make everyone else
like them when that's really hard for
them to do because that's just not who
they are and a lot of comedy comes of
that and this movie surprised the hell
out of me
I had such a good time with Keanu I
found it really funny and a lot of that
is due to the incredible chemistry
between key and Peele as well as some
really great writing some jokes on
common racial stereotypes and the way
they turn those on their heads and make
the best of it without being overly
offensive I really found clever and tons
of fun for the first two acts anyway it
really hits I saw this with a packed
theater and I was one of the loudest
people laughing which is really rare for
me I'm usually kind of a more reserved
laugher I was go falling I mean just
flat out spitting with laughter at some
of the jokes in this movie I mean just
for the scene alone in which ki tries to
explain to his newfound gang friends
that George Michaels is a really hard
dude oh my god I was dying but I keep
coming back to that chemistry because
that chemistry between them is so strong
and it's so easy to really gravitate
towards that because obviously they're
friends they make tons of things
together they make a lot of content
together and they're very funny together
but it really is important in a movie
like this in which our two main heroes
are essentially on screen
together for almost the entire film and
it really works it's almost like a
modern-day more adult version of Kenan &
Kel there's also a ton of in jokes
towards current films which is funny
because the movie Ratchet and Clank this
weekend also did that but this movie did
it far more successfully and a lot more
enjoyable with the movie falter for me
though was its third act because it gets
very action heavy and it lost a lot of
its steam for me because it got really
focused on these slow motion outs I feel
like that's just no longer funny movies
like casa da padre did that with Will
Ferrell or the other guys also with Will
Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg and it's just
it's overused also there are a ton of
unanswered questions when the movie is
over and certain things are being
explained no spoilers don't worry it
just causes you to be like wait what
about that and what about that and what
about that and what about that and that
and that and suddenly a ton of things
that happened previously no longer makes
any sense and it's one of those things
where you kind of have to just shrug and
go you know what it's just one of those
comedies just have fun with it which
mostly works because the movie is
actually funny but I have to be honest
when you look back on certain things
that happen the movie kind of falls
apart in certain ways because of
revelations made towards the end of the
film but I think the majority of people
who just want to go through this movie
and laugh and have a good time aren't
gonna care about that as much and will
probably forgive those flaws but someone
who is really digging deep into the
writing of this movie will probably
notice that those things no longer make
sense and it also features the most
adorable kitten normos ooming a number
of kittens probably played that
character that I've ever seen in a movie
I mean that thing was just I just wanted
to take it and just hug it forever I'm
gonna give Keano of be
surprising movie I was not anticipating
this at all but it really took me
off-guard and I had a great time with it
guys thank you so much as always for
watching if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes